give me some leg waves here maybe
there's definitely some nerves going on
I'm gonna show the entire Internet
activities I've never taken it off
seductively for somebody
I only take my clothes off to shower so
we'll know just to show what couples can
get out of performing of sexy and
sensual striptease dance for each other
is just a fun bonding I feel like
there's nowhere to go but up so that's
just you know hope for the best
you guys look scared first you're gonna
start just walking to your partner like
a very slow sexy way you're luring them
in when you get in front of them you'll
come down toss it on the floor
we don't need clothes around here I'm
definitely not wearing it as closer yes
try not to hump the air more so caress
the air you know
caress the air honey you'll lift your
right leg up boom take it down
[Music]
[Music]
there's no place like home in my head
you are like a young Swan I'm ready for
you what you go phony Oh hotter by the
minute my clothes just want to come on
this base is [ __ ] yoga it was great to
see him booty a little bit more I go
home floss it from that I call each
other I wish all of my exercises sexed
up like this I just kind of saw that he
was responding to stuff everything felt
extremely natural for me feel like this
is a sort of waves of discovery channel
that hitter Beyonce
I have felt warm maybe a little fuzzy
inside
it wasn't clear ahead of times that
stripping causing immense dizziness yeah
no place like home no home I just had
like a checklist in my head of
everything that I needed to do I really
kind of don't know what came over me
everything felt extremely natural I
didn't know I had certain muscles maybe
I might break these out every once in a
while
booty push-up is one of my favorite
things in the world now very sweaty I am
so hungry yeah I definitely think that
we should never break up though because
once the internet Jesus we will never be
able to date again gosh we are made for
each other